I just read that you got you got
randomly attacked I did I hadn't heard
that and it wasn't by Katrina what are
you doing I was drinking a coffee it was
9:00 in the morning oh no wonder you're
bright yeah I mean the nerves I know and
I was just chatting with a friend and
all of a sudden a fist appeared in my
face and that was it no it's what I love
about I read the story and this is where
you and I differ I'm like okay cuz I
could see getting punched in the face
while drinking coffee that could happen
to me sure
but then the story said that you
immediately got up and threw your coffee
in the dudes face and I was like that's
fight or flight and jack goes fight I
believe that I would probably go flight
yeah yeah well then he well so I I did
that through my coffee and like swung a
chair at him he like you know rattled
off some like you know fu you know MF
a--'s and all that and I was like all
right and then the cops came by that
point 35 minute response time which is
if he'd have stab me in the neck I
definitely would have been dead sure
and so he'd gone to another coffee shop
and by that point I'd got in my cars
like [ __ ] I'm gonna get this guy and
when he approached when the cops
approached him he took off running and
the cop comes like jogging posse and
he's like do you want us to arrest him
and I'm like what like yes that would be
great yeah he then tried to stab the cop
with a screwdriver and then in that
point about 400 police magically
appeared in about three seconds
so I'm like oh they can get places
quickly yeah and then they tasered him
and he's in jail
was he homeless yes crazy what he well
you know in this day and age you can't
make assumptions here to be sure anyway
that anyway tries to stab a cop of the
screwdrivers probably crazy yeah better
weapon we're not gonna assume his gender
or his mental state appeared to be yes
he was pushing around a lime scooter
with lots of bags on and off his aroma
led me to believe you hadn't showered in
a while so you got lucky though because
if he had a screwdriver ah you're lucky
you only punched yes it's true but I
loved that his response was okay
got in this fight and I'm gonna still
gonna go to another coffee man I need a
coffee after that was like cuz I was
like waiting in my car in front of the
other one just kind of like laying back
like looking he he was like just
chilling like no big deal like eating a
muffin so you hit him with the chair and
then he just took off he left me yeah
but not and not in a hurry either he was
just like doom with his little scooter
with bags on it
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM a